[Music]
four years ago I was basically
unemployed I Wanderer with no home
but now I'm a husband and a father
and I wouldn't have it any other way
and I did pops my job was a little less
stressful than yours
oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the king
of Atlantis
half a billion people
of every known species in the sea
call this place home
but that doesn't mean they don't like me
I'm gonna kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds there
I'm gonna murder his family
and burn his kingdom to Ash
it must be stopped for a global meltdown
is imminent
I think I know someone might be able to
help us
you look rough
good job little brother high five do not
call me brother
I cannot believe you let this happen
yeah well I hate this job true king
built Bridges right
Shoe King builds Bridges
we need to find Manta he's different now
he's stronger than before
it's the black Trident
during King outland's time there were
Seven Kingdoms
it was a curse upon them all
to try to start magic is spreading
he means to end the bloodline
[Music]
I don't know if I said
we can't leave our children a world
without hope
you're not as bad at this as you think
if you lead
the Seven Kingdoms will follow
[Music]